i guess this is the first wake up call
for me that i've had to really
think about my internet privacy it took
me way too long to make my facebook
uh my my facebook privates um that was
that should have been the first stage
but yeah
i think the problem with internet like
celebrities or whatever nowadays
is that there's a difference between say
it's you know
someone who's signed to a big film or
someone gets picked up by a music label
like old school celebrities who
there was this system by which they got
picked up and they knew they were gonna
be famous but the problem is anyone can
be famous now
anyone can have their privacy leaked and
you know
not really think about the consequences
of really going through their entire
[ __ ] past
and just making it private or you know
making it not public because
we were we were teenagers we don't
remember every [ __ ]
site that we signed up to oh my god like
i
i don't know how many one of my like old
forum like old anime forum profile
pictures are still
like public or whatever you know because
i signed up to a lot of sites back then
because i was a teenager but
it's it's something that you you don't
really think about
when you don't make content on the
internet because you don't no one really
expects to be famous or no one really
expects to have an
audience or anything like that yeah um
and i feel like i i do wonder if
like the newer generation is gonna think
about this when whenever
they do anything or if we're just gonna
continue to be stupid kids that
i don't really think about anything well
i would i would like
for it to be the first option if i'm
being honest just because like you know
again it's like
i i think that whole pre-notion of like
yeah you know you you should expect
your privacy to be you know hacked and
slashed yeah
because people talk like that that
weirds me out yeah yeah it's like it's
like what is it about suddenly being you
know quote unquote famous you know
regardless of how you view
you know fame to be where it's suddenly
like oh well you know you
you have a presence on the internet that
you share openly with a large audience
so that means that
you know you don't have a privacy if
it's on the internet it's not private
anymore it's literally like the same
argument as like
old-school paparazzi have you ever seen
any [ __ ] interviews with like any
paparazzi photographer it's the most
they're all [ __ ]
yeah it's it it's the most like you see
these people
openly being arseholes and they're
they're just they they're proud of it
they're [ __ ] proud of it like i think
i remember the last one i saw was i
think anthony's
like sitting down with a paparazzi i
thought yeah literally
everyone he interviewed was just the the
biggest class they are sold
you know they do that whole [ __ ] of
like oh if i don't do it someone else is
going to get it yeah it's like how about
none of you [ __ ] dude
and it sucks because like i think 99 of
people again who are watching this i was
like super chill
don't but like think that way there's
all it takes that one percent to
make your life happen yeah yeah like and
that's unfortunate right because
you know i i don't i don't have any
resentment to mine like audience or
anything like that no most of them are
super [ __ ] nice
exactly just a [ __ ] shame that some
people are just like i'm a [ __ ]
ruin this man's life yeah it's a shame
that you know you have to change your
behavior
for literally one percent of the people
watching you and you know that most
most of everyone that you interact with
is just going to be a generally nice
cool person yeah and then it just sucks
that there's that small percentage that
unfortunately it's it's that small
percentage that ruins it for everyone
and it's i guess i guess that's just the
world in general right yeah yeah
yeah but you know we'd be living in the
utopia if everyone was being honest and
kind of
flying cars we're not flying cars by now
that's not the case right now some of us
are still walking on the ground
so yeah